aquí tenemos la imagen de un airbus a
380 y yo tenía curiosidad por saber
cuánto tiempo le tomaría a este avión
despegar busque las especificaciones y
me encontré que su velocidad de despegue
velocidad de
despegue
es de 280 kilómetros por hora
y si estamos hablando de velocidad
recuerden que siempre debemos indicar la
dirección y no solo la magnitud en este
caso la dirección de esta velocidad va
en el sentido de la pista que está
recorriendo en la dirección positiva de
esta estuve buscando otras
especificaciones y simplificando las de
manera que podamos hacer cálculos con
una aceleración constante aunque la
realidad es muy difícil tener una
aceleración constante en el estricto
sentido de la palabra pero me encontré
que la aceleración a aceleración es de
1.0 metros por segundo cada segundo
después de que pasa un segundo este
avión irá un metro por segundo más
rápido que en el segundo anterior y
tenemos esta forma de escribir esta
aceleración o también una forma un poco
más reducida aunque esta forma es un
poquito más clara porque podemos ver que
aquí es un metro por segundo cada
segundo lo que aumenta la velocidad pero
para simplificar también se escribe 1.0
metros
por segundo al cuadrado y lo que
queremos responder nuestro interrogante
es cuánto tiempo
tarde
en despegar en despegar
y eso es lo que queremos responder y
para resolver esto lo primero que mi
cerebro me pide hacer es convertir estos
datos a las unidades correctas la
aceleración es tenemos en metros por
segundo al cuadrado y la velocidad en
kilómetros por hora así que vamos a
convertir esta velocidad en metros por
segundo entonces tenemos que son 280
kilómetros por hora y lo primero que
quiero hacer es cancelar estas horas de
aquí quitar estas horas y convertirlas a
segundo entonces para eso tengo que
multiplicar todo esto por algo que tenga
horas en el numerador de manera que
pueda cancelar las horas en el
denominador de aquí y esto lo voy a
dividir por segundos pues quiero que
queden mis unidades de tiempo en
segundos así que x algo que tiene horas
en el numerador y segundos en el
denominador y bueno qué cantidad es la
que voy a multiplicar cuántos segundos
hay en una hora
una hora hay 3600 segundos 60 minutos en
una hora y cada minuto son 60 segundos
60 x 60 son 3600 pero como quiero hacer
los cálculos todos de una sola vez aquí
voy a multiplicar todo esto por algo que
me permita quitar los kilómetros que
están en el numerador de la velocidad y
quiero dejarlo en metros que tengo que
multiplicar para poder eliminar esos
kilómetros pues tengo que multiplicar
algo que tenga kilómetros en el
denominador y que tenga metros en el
numerador y bueno qué cantidad tengo que
poner acá pues voy a poner cuántos
metros hay en un kilómetro hay mil
metros en un kilómetro y ahora sí ya
podemos hacer las operaciones vamos a
trabajar primero con las unidades aquí
tengo que estas horas se cancelan con
las horas de aquí arriba y aquí tengo
que esos kilómetros se cancelan con
estos otros kilómetros por lo tanto si
hago todas las operaciones numéricas me
va a quedar que las unidades van a ser
en metros por segundo como estaba yo
buscando y massa la multiplicación de
doscientos ochenta
por 1000 metros entre 3.600 y las
unidades que me quedaron son metros
sobre segundo y esto es igual bueno sacó
mi calculadora hago las operaciones 280
por 1000 entre 3.600 y nos dan 77 puntos
777 que vamos a redondear aquí vemos que
sólo hay un dígito significativo y aquí
arriba no está claro si este doscientos
ochenta kilómetros por hora es una
aproximación o si es la velocidad real
pero bueno por facilidad vamos a
redondear esto a 78 metros por segundo
esta es una velocidad bastante rápida
imagínense son 78 metros cada segundo
qué es lo que recorre este avión son
casi tres cuartas partes de la longitud
de un campo de fútbol cada segundo pero
eso no es lo que queremos resolverlo
queremos saber cuánto tiempo dura el
despegue o cuánto tiempo tarde podríamos
hacer los cálculos mentalmente tenemos
que la aceleración es un metro por
segundo por segundo es decir que cada
segundo la velocidad va a aumentar a un
metro por segundo si comenzamos con una
velocidad de 0 después de un segundo la
velocidad va a ser de un metro por
segundo después de dos segundos la
velocidad será de dos metros por segundo
al tercer segundo la velocidad será de
tres metros por segundo
cuanto vamos a tardar en alcanzar los 78
metros por segundo pues vamos a tardar
78 segundos aproximadamente o lo que es
también aproximadamente un minuto con 18
segundos y ahora este cálculo mental que
hicimos vamos a verificarlo usando la
fórmula de la aceleración vamos a
verificar nuestro resultado
queremos que la aceleración que es
vector le ponemos su flechita aquí es
igual al cambio en la velocidad y
recordemos que así como la aceleración
es un vector la velocidad también es un
vector y le ponemos su flecha encima el
cambio en la velocidad
el cambio en el tiempo y lo que quiero
conocer es el cambio en el tiempo
entonces vamos a despejar voy a
multiplicar la aceleración por el camino
el tiempo y el otro lado también lo voy
a multiplicar por el cambio en el tiempo
la selección por el cambio en el tiempo
es igual si multiplico este otro lado
por el camino el tiempo se cancelan
estos dos cambios en el tiempo y me
queda el cambio en la velocidad y como
lo que me interesa cambian el tiempo voy
a dividir ambos lados de esta ecuación
entre la aceleración de manera que me
queda que el cambio en el tiempo es
igual al cambio en la velocidad entre la
aceleración
y ahora si yo tengo estos valores que lo
sustituyó aquí esto va a ser igual a el
cambio la velocidad que es de 78 metros
por segundo entre un metro por segundo
al cuadrado que es mi aceleración y
ahora aquí voy a trabajar 78 entre 1 me
queda 78 y las unidades son metros por
segundo las que están aquí arriba y lo
voy a multiplicar por el recíproco de
las unidades que se encuentran aquí
abajo que es segundo al cuadrado entre
metro puedo simplificar estas unidades
quitando los metros de aquí los metros
de acá un segundo de aquí se elimina con
el segundo de aquí abajo me queda aquí
además un segundo que es la unidad del
tiempo lo cual es correcto me va a
quedar que el cambio en el tiempo es de
78 segundos que es lo mismo que obtuve
aquí de esta otra manera cuando hice mi
cálculo mental